come on
it reminds me of those sort of plastic
flyways you used to have when you were a
kid you know you got for like 50p you
know down at this sort of summer fair or
something and the sort of surface of the
ball is sort of it's it's very smooth if
it's almost a perfect sphere and what
this means is when you when your foot
comes into contact with the ball it's
very difficult to get any grip on it so
it means you can't spin the ball so sort
of a talented footballer like not like
these guys over here but a talented
footballer you know when he strikes the
ball he tries to put some spin on it so
he can get top spin so the ball will dip
and move in the air
well this ball is very difficult to have
any of that level of control
basically what you'd like to do is give
it a bit of spin give it a bit of
angular momentum but with this ball when
you strike it you can't get that spin
and all you do is you give it what's
called linear momentum it just moves in
a sort of forward direction without
spinning
you kicked
they never miss the germans
i mean i guess they must have done some
simulations but did they do simulations
with real people because the end of the
day this bull's got to be used by real
footballers
and then you know they have the final
saying we've seen this world cup that
clearly something's not right
um
how do you do um